hey youtubers is Charlie so quick heads
up I'm actually shooting this in my
office just because I have a movie
screen to go see tonight I'll be doing
that later this week but that's why
everything looks a little bit weird in
case you didn't hear the big news this
morning Gwendoline Christie who plays
Brianna in the show was actually cast in
Star Wars Episode 7 so I'm really hoping
she gets to be a Jedi I'll talk about it
more in my Star Wars video tomorrow be
sure to subscribe to get that
but right now congratulations to Raz
ransom you were the winner of the
giveaway you win a $20 Amazon gift card
I'll be contacting you on your channel
for details it's just my way of saying
thank you to all you guys for being so
awesome so the next round of the
giveaway will start next week so it's
question time careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
but question number one Thomas asks what
are already in the Hound going to do now
so I think that by the end of the season
that their show plot will catch up with
the book plot for book readers please
use the you know spoiler below the fold
method if you want to make specific
references I was really happy when the
show started prolonging their
relationship though I really like the
two of those actors together loving
characters on Game of Thrones is pretty
dangerous though you never really know
who's gonna die next there are only two
hours left in the show but I fully
expect that their plot will just lead
right up to that last episode question
number two Chris asks where is the
blackfish yeah we haven't seen him since
the red wedding dun dun dun he's still
alive but he's a captive of the phrase
along with Greatjon umber I don't know
if we're gonna see him before the end of
the season though but he will come back
at some point question number three
Jenny asks will Arya and Sansa meet I
seem like the show really wanted us to
think that but I don't think it's gonna
happen I think that Arie in the Hound
are gonna turn around and go somewhere
else as for Sansa and Littlefinger
she said shall we go and dyed her hair
like she did in the books so I think
they'll be taking Robyn on that big tour
of his lands like Littlefinger was
talking to yon Royce about he really
just wants to keep Robin under his thumb
and it's really hard to do when his
guards are standing around the guards
obey Robin not Littlefinger so if Robin
threw a tantrum and wanted to make
people fly the guards would totally make
it happen
thus Littlefinger separates Robin from
the moon door
question number 4 mohab stur asks isn't
Circe's daughter still in Dorne
will this be bad for her so Prince
Durant is actually pretty cool headed
compared
- his brother oberyn martell and the
sand snakes yes people are flipping out
just look at ilaria space this is the
face of all their faces but I think that
they're waiting til season five to deal
with a lot of what actually ends up
happening so you will have to read books
four and five if you don't want to wait
I don't think the Martel's would ever
hurt a child
Marcella is engaged Prince Doran's son
and Oberyn even said point blank she was
safe
whenever Cersei and Tywin were up in his
face at the purple wedding it's not like
Joffrey torturing and tormenting Sansa
and King's Landing and just for
reference Myrcella is younger than Sansa
if you look at the picture of her it
seems like the show will age her up just
because the actors who plays her is
growing up so fast that happens to child
actors on the show all the time just
look at Tommen question number five Jake
asks what's gonna happen to Tyrion now
that Oberyn is dead and is the mountain
dead so technically Tyrion lost his
trial by combat
because Oberyn died before the mountain
fell so yeah he is sentenced to death
right after all that went down though he
probably would have been taken back down
to the black cells to wait for Ilyn
Payne to chop his head off you know Ned
Stark style the mountain as far as we
know is still alive and just gushing
blood from all the pike wounds that
Oberyn gave him the reason he's so hard
to kill is because he has such a high
body mass the weird thing about Game of
Thrones I feel is unless you see their
head leave their body or their skull
gets squished like a grape they are not
dead unless you're in the north and
necromancy is a threat then you have to
burn them to ashes question number six
Ariadna asks do you think that Daenerys
overreacted to Sir Jorah
to be fair most people probably would
have chopped his head off she's just
getting used to being a queen and she's
really insecure
hizdahr and all the other slaving
families are giving her problems and the
wise masters still need to be dealt with
plus she just came off the high that she
got from crucifying all those people
whenever she entered the city so
combined insecurity with blood lust and
you get murderous rage remember who her
father was - she's not like the Mad King
but I think her reaction was appropriate
once you catch someone lying you really
can't be sure whether or not they're
telling the truth
so if Sir Jorah wants to make it back
into her trust circle he's gonna have to
do something really epic question number
7 Camille asks what happened but
Sansa and Baelish in her room after the
camera left ooh that's pretty hot I
think he just left I don't think
anything really you know funny business
went on I did see that a bunch of you
wondered if they had sex or not I don't
think they did in the books whenever
this was happening that was not the case
george RR martin spells it out a little
more explicitly but i think the show is
just being more ambiguous about it with
those crazy long looks i think that the
two of them have just come to an
understanding now you know she doesn't
trust him not implicitly but she trusts
everyone else way less so she's just
gonna form an alliance with him she
needs all the help she can get and I
think that she senses that Littlefinger
isn't gonna torture her like the
Lannisters so just think of it as like a
temporary alliance question number 8
Sergio asks what would have happened if
Jaime had not lost his hand and fought
his Tyrians champion so I don't think
that Tywin would have ever let a fight
like that go down he would have stopped
it before it started
he would have engineered some plot to
keep Jaime from stepping into the ring
he's more than happy to be done with
Tyrion but Jaime is still his prize but
really if Jaime hadn't lost his hand I
think the events that happened right
after that would have gone down much
differently I still think he would have
helped Brienne but he wouldn't be the
same person inside he wouldn't have been
as open to turning his life around he
would still be like the same selfish
he was before but there's no way
that I think a fight between the
mountain and Jaime would have ever gone
down he did kill a person like the
mountain called the smiling Knight so
technically he did kill someone almost
as big as the mountain so I think he
would have had a chance against them
question number 9 misty asks why is
Stannis the only one who's helping out
at the wall
mostly because no one else takes it
seriously the threat of the White
Walkers are at least no one with the
power to do something about it I think
it's important to remember though that
Stannis is the only person that we've
seen say he's going to help out that
doesn't mean that he's going to be the
only person who ever helps out with the
White Walkers
but because the show is going to last
for about eight seasons I don't think
we're going to get any crazy white
Walker battles until like the last two
seasons so in the near future yeah it
will probably just be Stannis helping
out and if he doesn't make it there by
the end of this season I think it's
going to be the first couple of episodes
in season 5 when we see him at the wall
question number 10 Inkheart asks was
that simple
mr. that squished the Beatles in the
books so Orson Lannister was not in the
books I think that was just Dan and Dave
trying to get existential like Tyrion is
at the end of his rope and he's pretty
sure he's gonna die this time see that
crazy look on his face whenever he was
telling the story he's a little bit
drunk but he's completely out of his
mind and just wondering out loud if
there's any reason for all this violence
you know a lot of you thought that it
might be a metaphor for George are
Martin just you know squishing his
characters like bugs because he can and
to be fair I think that it probably
means both things it's probably both an
existential reference and like a sly
wink to george RR martin on to bonus
question so Garrick asks will the
Bolton's take Winterfell and rule in the
north and if Roose dies does that mean
that Ramsay will rule yes but they don't
need Winterfell right now they don't
actually need to be in Winterfell to be
considered wardens of the north that's
just a title the reality is is that the
North is so big just like Roose said in
his speech calling yourself the ruler
and all the people that live there
thinking you're their ruler are
completely different things
so right now Roose is more like the
ruler of a clump of dirt in the north
nobody up there really considers him
their leader and to answer your second
question yes Ramsay is now an official
air so if Roose died everything of his
would just pass to Ramsay and one last
one
Ashleigh asks was the fight scene like
it was in the books pretty much but in
the books the mountain punches Oberyn so
hard that his face breaks apart in his
eyeballs pop out I don't think that he
squished him with his bare hands I think
it was just the punch that splattered
him but yes he did get splattered in the
books the rest of the fight was taken
directly off the page like when he was
dancing around trying to get the
confession that speech was directly out
of the books so I hope everyone takes
the next week to rewatch the episode a
lot of times you know once the shock
wears off it's a little easier to think
analytically about the episode just
because it really was a big WTF moment
at the end and thank you so much for so
many questions these are always so much
fun to do my next bonus video will
probably be for my favorite prophecies
in Game of Thrones since there are so
many I might just do a top 10 list also
since there are only two more episodes
left I wanted to start talking about
later this summer because there's going
to be a couple weeks before Doctor Who
starts up again here's where you can
really help me out
either let me know in the comments or on
Twitter or Facebook whether you just
want Game of Thrones bonus videos every
Sunday until Doctor Who comes back in
August or do you want me to try and work
something in that I haven't done yet
I'll still be doing bonus videos for a
game of Thrones regardless so don't
worry about that but I'd like to find
something fun to do in like the 8 or 9
weeks before Doctor Who starts I'll talk
about it a little bit more in the next
couple of weeks we still have a couple
more episodes so right now you can click
here to get my review of the episode and
you can click here to learn about my top
10 fighters in the show alive or dead
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives